le combat d'une vie pour les salariés
d'un des fleurons de l'industrie de la
vie de saint claude mais aussi du haut
jura la fonderie mbf ne rouvrira pas ses
portes après plus d'un an de lutte
redressement judiciaire classique
possibilité de reprise plusieurs étapes
qui n'ont finalement abouti qu'à une
liquidation
on pensait vraiment que l'état allait
nous soutenir
faire fléchir les constructeurs en notre
faveur en fait ils nous ont tous lâché
il ya beaucoup de salariés sont un peu
perdus ils savent pas où aller
il serait bien que il nous accompagne
aussi financièrement parce que deux ans
de chômage s'est pas c'est pas grand
chose avec ce qui se passe actuellement
en france je suis pas persuadé qu'on
puisse reconduire parce que pour
rebondir pour d'activité alors que nous
on avait un savoir-faire donc un bel
outil de travail d'ailleurs tout le
monde là dessus reconnaît ce savoir
faire et ce tout petit travail et le
petit coup de pouce pluie devait nous
donner a pas été fait et on n'avait pas
besoin de tous à
2 186 salariés sur le carreau des hommes
et femmes spécialisées dans la
fabrication de pièces précieuses pour
l'industrie automobile dans les groupes
renault restée en tice à travers sa
filiale citroën depuis avril l'état a
débloqué un fonds d'accompagnement et de
reconversion de 50 millions d'euros pas
assez pour des employés qui garde espoir
en la période électorale normalement
peux tu es ça et renault avait émis un
accord de principe d'accompagner ce
projet de coopérative c'est ce qu'on a
ramené au bout on avait un projet
industriel viable
sauf que la décision a été tout autre
puisque leur stratégie c'est de
délocaliser cette filière là ce dans
d'autres pays on a souhaité interpeller
le premier candidat qui est manuel
macron
malheureusement ça s'est terminé en 8
heures de garde à vue pour pour nous
puisqu'il nous a pas souhaité nous
rencontrer une fermeture aux
conséquences économiques également pour
la ville de saint-claude son maire jean
lui nier dénonce les choix du
gouvernement de sacrifier la fonderie
française en se tournant vers l'étranger
on peut même pas discuter c'est pas
possible on pouvait faire faire
fabriquer en hongrie roumanie tchéquie
ou en espagne comme les moteurs qui
avait été promis 1 mb/s qui sont partis
en espagne des emplois en moins mais bon
les crises se sont succédé et la ville
depuis 2009 en 12 ans a perdu le quart
de sa population plus du quart de sa
population nous avons perdu ce 3200
habitants c'est qui est énorme ce qui
fait que c'est ces crises successives
nous ont fait passer en dessous de dix
mille habitants nous prive d'une
dotation essentiels qui s'appelle la
dotation de solidarité urbaine de 1
million 2 est aujourd'hui moi je sais
pas où trouver le million 2 qui me
manquent pour boucler mon budget une
partie des salariés de la fonderie ont
décidé en juillet de porter plainte
contre leur direction et le groupe
renault afin de récupérer des indemnités
supplémentaires le patron de mbf quant à
lui fait l'objet d'une enquête pour abus
de biens sociaux liés à des mouvements
de fonds suspects